after rejecting a ceasefire call by
Turkey and Russia last week warlord
Khalifa Haftar changed his mind a few
hours before it was due to go into
effect the general command of the Libyan
Arab armed forces announces a ceasefire
in the western side of Libya the
ceasefire starts from one minute past
midnight on the 12th of January 2020 the
other party should stop any type of
military operation at the same time we
will respond harshly to any violation of
this ceasefire in a joint press
conference earlier vladimir putin an
angular merkel made their position clear
and into the ongoing violence in Libya
including peace talks to take place in
Berlin it is essential to put an end to
the opposition between the Libyan
National Army led by hafter and the
government of national Accord half those
forces have been trying to seize the
capital Tripoli from the UN backed the
government their attempts have so far
fallen short but his forces have gained
ground
violence is escalating the European and
African leaders
fearing the conflict could destabilize
several countries turkish President
Recep Tayyip Erdogan has also called for
fighting to stop German Chancellor
Angela Merkel is hoping Turkish Russian
efforts to secure peace will end in
success and once the United Nations
involved we agreed to the conference in
Berlin to be held very soon in order to
start a process of a peaceful Libya the
talks want to include Libya's warring
parties and Merkel says they will no
doubt have to play a significant role to
help in the conflict when we think there
is so much disunity in the international
community they have to have a conference
after has been backed by Egypt the
United Arab Emirates France and Russia
while they and back the government by
turkey the fact that both warring
factions have now agreed to a ceasefire
does not mean an end to hostilities
especially with you and back the
government demanding that Hefner's
forces pull out from southern tripoli as
a prerequisite to any settlement in this
conflict muhammad abdul wahid al jazeera
Tripoli Oh William Lawrence is a
professor of political science at George
Washington University and also a former
US diplomat he says the negotiations led
by Russia and Turkey have been useful
what was really surprising about what
happened is that hefter agreed and that
was a direct result of Turkey Russian
negotiations which were primarily about
Syria but also about Libya and those of
us that follow Syria and Libya closely
see that the two negotiations have been
connected and it's probably the case
since the ceasefire benefits the Turks
more than the Russians in Libya that
concessions were made on Syria and of
course right now the Russians are trying
to get more positions in Syria
all of this sort of sidelines the
European Union as well and puts Turkey
and Russia as the most important
international brokers in the conflict in
a way we haven't seen before so
everybody wants to see Libya stabilized
and a lot of countries put a bet on half
dar that he could do it not really
understanding the the the revolutionary
context that prompted the whole problem
in Libya and the fact that much of the
West would never submit to an
authoritarian state under half dar and
so there's a lot of reassessing going on
the French have reassessed even the
Egyptians to agree I've reassessed and
not without dissing themselves from heft
our everyone seems to be more in a
position now than they even were three
four months ago to participate in good
faith in the peace talks